what I want to do in this video is start
to visualize the balance sheet for a
simple bank and so we can start to
understand the actual mechanics for how
a bank accounts for its assets and
liabilities in the context of a
fractional reserve system so first let's
just give a general idea of what a
balance sheet is and I go into a lot
more depth in other playlists but when
we talk about a balance sheet we're
really just talking about how many
assets to something have and how many
liabilities offset it and then how much
is left over for the owners of the firm
or whatever we're talking about so for
example so for example if I have let's
say just let's just say generalize it to
any type of company let's say that they
have so over here I'll draw their assets
so their assets I'll do it in this green
box the height of it is kind of the
magnitude of their assets let's say that
there's some company that has 100
million dollars in assets and assets you
probably understand it's something that
gives you some type of benefit the more
formal definition is something that
gives you some future value and it's
generally considered to have some
positive economic value so it could be
cash because cash can be converted into
other things you can go buy a cow and
that cow can provide milk for you and
give you future benefit a cow itself
would be an asset a building would be an
asset because it gives you the future
value of giving you shelter so assets
could be anything but here for the sake
of this company we could even visualize
it as cash if you like so it has a
hundred million dollars of assets and
let's say it has some liabilities so
let's say this company right over here
has sixty million in liabilities and I'm
trying to do it roughly equal to the
height it's not exact but let's say that
they have 60 million in liabilities and
liabilities are just obligations so it
owes people sixty million dollars worth
of stuff and so when you look at it this
way this entity here which could be a
company affirm it could even this you
could even call this a person if this
was a person they'd have a hundred
million dollars of assets but they owe
sixty million of that hundred or you
could say they owe sixty and you could
view it of that hundred million so they
would have forty million left over for
themselves if you were to say what is
the value of this how much do the owners
of this entity actually how much are
they worth
from this entity it would be the hundred
minus the sixty they have a hundred they
owe sixty so the owners
right over here would be 40 million
dollars so that's really kind of the
value of what the owners have and it's
called owners owner's equity so that's
just a basic primary primer in assets
and liabilities and now I want to use I
want to build on that to think about
what's actually happening in a
fractional reserve system with the bank
and what we're going to see is the way
it's actually done mechanically in a
modern fractional reserve system is
slightly different than the way you
would conceptualize it the way you
actually I've been conceptualizing it
for you guys because that's just an
easier way to think about things so
let's just say we're going to go start a
bank so let's say I I want to start a
bank and what I do is I go and I take I
go by I don't know let's say I go by a
10 million dollar existing bank so here
I have an asset which is my equipment
and the building and all of the ID
computers and all of the things all of
the things that can essentially run a
bank and that's worth that's worth ten
million dollars and this is my owner's
equity so I have 10 million dollars of
owner's equity maybe do it in those same
colors that I did so let me do this in
that green color so this is an asset and
I have no liabilities yet let's just say
that I inherited that money or that was
just money that I had saved up so I went
I bought a 10 million dollar asset and
so my equity since there's no offsetting
liabilities is ten million dollars so
this is my owner's equity right over
here is 10 million dollars so I'll just
call it equity now let's say that you
know you you lot you're impressed with
my building and my IT systems and the
number of ATMs that I have around town
so you decide that you want to deposit
some money with me so let's say that you
take your you take a wheelbarrow and in
your wheelbarrow you come and you
deposit let's say you deposit a hundred
million dollars in my bank in cash so
these are cash reserves
these are Federal Reserve notes that
you're depositing in my bank so I'll
draw these as assets so this is so let
me do a hundred million just should be
about ten times as high as what I've
already drawn so you're going to come
here and you're going to deposit you are
going to deposit a hundred million
dollars so this is a hundred million
dollars one hundred million of
of I'll call it cache of cash will
visualize it as physical cash and it
goes into these vaults that I had
purchased and so that's the asset that I
got but obviously you're not just giving
me this cash then I would be 100 million
dollars richer you're keeping that your
you want that on demand you want that in
the checking account so that you can
write checks against it and access it
from your ATM and so I have an
offsetting liability my my offsetting
liability is that this is essentially a
demand deposit for you so this is I
guess the way we can view it is the way
we can view it is we could write it as a
checkable checkable checkable deposit
and i'm viewing it from the bank's
perspective and that's why it's a
liability because someone can hand me a
check and I would have to give them some
money this is this is an obligation if
someone writes a check against these
deposits to someone else
that's an obligation that I is the bank
half the surface I could call this just
checking accounts or checking accounts
of person a maybe that makes it easier
to ace checking account is a liability
for me so let me call it if I haven't
called them person a already I'm calling
them now person a's checking account
checking account and that's a liability
because person a can come at any time
and they can demand one hundred million
dollars of cash now this right over here
I haven't done anything fractional yet
this is just as just regular so far this
would be equivalent to full reserve
banking I'm just keeping person a's
money safe but we know in a fractional
reserve system i can lend out a good bit
of money and so that's essentially what
i could then do if we're talking about
fractional reserve i can lend out 90% of
this money I could lend out 90% of this
so let me take out 90% so let me clear
this right over here so let me clear
that and so let's say I took ninety
percent of it lent it out and so we only
have ten million of the original cash
there as reserves and I call them
reserves now but that's ten million of
the original so I'm going to have ten
million of reserves left and everything
else I lent out so everything else I
lent out so 1990 million
I lent 90 million
of lending so we can even visualize it
as big stacks of cash that I hand it out
to people and then you might say well
okay I didn't just give that to those
people in exchange for that they are
saying I'm going to pay me back and so
that's an asset if you borrow money from
me it's an obligation for you it's a
liability for you but it's an asset for
me let me make this clear so if I'm a
bank if I'm a bank and there's a
borrower I there is a borrower there is
a borrower and if I give the borrower if
I give the borrower a dollar if I give
them a dollar you could visualize it
although it's not exactly how it works
is that they give an IOU they give the
bank an IOU I owe you one dollar at some
future date now from the bank's point of
view this IOU is an asset they're
essentially exchanging assets the bank
is giving it a dollar the borrower is
giving an IOU
from the borrower's point of view the
dollar is an asset and this IOU is a
liability but from the bank's point of
view there's like oh I have this IOU
maybe I could give this to someone else
maybe I could sell this I'll you this I
use going to give me future benefit
because assuming this person is good for
their money
they're going to give that money back
and that's the same reason why a check
is a liability of the bank if you write
a check to someone the bank has a
responsibility to if someone were to
give that check to the bank to give them
cash so the similar way when the bank
lends out all of this money they're
going to get IOUs from all the people
that they lent it to so they're going to
have they're going to get 90 million of
IOUs we could say 90 million worth of
loans but you really could just view
those as these are io u--'s to other
people this is an asset because it's
going to give some future benefit at
some future time now I'm going to leave
you there because what I did here this
is conceptually identical to everything
we've been talking about this is how
frankly most people visualize fractional
reserve lending you get you get a
hundred million reserves you lend out
ninety million of that reserves and to
exchange that for an asset which is
essentially an IOU but we'll see in the
next videos this isn't exactly true what
a bank can actually do is actually
create it can actually take just the ten
million of reserves and then it can
create these assets which are
functionally equivalent it looks a
little bit shady the first time you
think about it but they are actually
functionally equivalent so it's not
as shady as you might initially think it
to be and we'll cover that in the next
video